[MUSIC PLAYING]
RODNEY: In the book
"Bored and Brilliant--
Rediscovering the Lost
Art of Spacing Out,"
Manoush Zomorodi explains the
connection between boredom
and being unplugged, and
how that state of mind
can ignite original thinking.
Through reviews with
scientists, famous artists,
and regular people,
Zomorodi explains
why putting the greater
emphasis on doing nothing
is vital in an age of
constant notifications
and digital distractions.
She explores how we can harness
boredom's hidden benefits
to become our most
productive selves.
Bored and brilliant--
it's permission to unplug.
Please welcome the author
and host of the podcast
"Note to Self,"
Manoush Zomorodi.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Thank
you so much, Rodney.
Thank you, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks for being patient
with me and hanging out.
I don't know.
You rush off to
meetings at Google,
or are you involved enough
that you don't have to do that?
I don't know.
So I'm just going to
play you a little video
just so you get a
sense of what I've
been working on for the
last couple of years.
Let's see if it plays.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK, so what I'm
going to do is I'm
going to tell you about
how this book came to be,
because it's kind of unusual.
I think it's truly the first--
and this is a mouthful-- the
first podcast crowdsourced
project to be
turned into a book.
I'm going to take
that title for myself.
I know everyone's
been clamoring for it,
but I'm going to take it.
So I'm going to tell you
about the genesis of it.
I'm going to play you a little
bit of audio, some of the stuff
that I've been making, because
it all really comes down
to the podcast that
I've been making.
And then I'm going to tell
you about the book tour
that I've been on for
the last two weeks
because it's been my own little
focus group across the country,
and it's been fascinating to
hear the people who've come out
to spend time with me and
what's on their minds,
which I think is interesting
to all of us making the stuff
that they use.
So if you don't
know it, my podcast
is called "Note to Self."
It's part of New
York Public Radio.
I started out as a
hardcore journalist.
I was with the BBC.
I was with Reuters,
and my job was
flying around the
world for a long time
and covering hot spots.
And then, once I had
kids, I was really more
covering business and tech.
And then I got into
podcasting, and I realized
that my job had changed.
It was less about reporting
on the developments that
was happening at
companies like yours,
but really, more
that as a podcast,
there was an intimacy that
was there with my community,
that people--
when you listen,
there was this sense
that we were talking
to each other.
There was conversation, and
that what people really wanted
was some help.
They were feeling as though the
world was moving at a really
accelerating pace, and
they felt unmoored by it
because as you know, technology
is changing the way that we
fall in love, the way that we
parent, the way that we work--
everything.
And people didn't
know how to handle it.
And so that's what "Note to
Self" really evolved into.
And so one of the
things that I did
was an interactive project
that was called "The Bored
and Brilliant Project--
The Lost Art of Spacing
Out," and this was in 2015.
And the genesis of this was
actually that the podcast--
it was doing well.
It was 2014.
Podcasting was starting
to take off, which
was super exciting for me.
And I'd give us a
B-plus, A-minus.
And I had this moment
where I was like, OK, how
am I going to step up my game?
It was a cliched moment to have.
How am I going to come
up with better ideas?
And I had this
feeling like, well,
when was the last time that I
did come up with my best ideas?
And it was such a cliche.
It was like, oh, when
I'm driving in the car
and staring out the window.
I was never bored,
is what I realized.
I realized that all
the cracks in my day--
when I was waiting to get a
cup of coffee or I was waiting
to get on the subway
or to pick up my kids,
all those little moments
when I used to be spacing out
or thinking things through or
whatever, I now was looking--
somebody did leave
their phone up here.
I was looking at this thing.
And I guess I was like,
well, I guess never
being bored-- is
that a good thing?
I guess it's a good thing.
That's what they tell us.
Only boring people
get bored, right?
But then I started
to wonder, well,
what actually happens in our
brains when we get bored?
Or more importantly, what
could be happening to all of us
if we never get
bored ever again,
if we don't experience this
human state that has, I think,
been with us for millennia?
And so I reached out to my
listeners, and I was like,
are you guys thinking
about this too?
Are you wondering how your
smartphones are changing
your thinking patterns?
Would you be interested
in maybe, I don't know,
doing a week of
experiments where
we see that if we changed
our smartphone habits how
it would affect our thinking?
And I thought a couple
hundred people would sign up
to play with me for a
week, and within 48 hours,
20,000 people signed up.
And I was like, whoa,
OK, this is a thing.
A lot of people
are feeling this--
people like [? Carin. ?]
[AUDIO PLAYBACK]
- Hi, my name is
[? Carin. ?] I am
a New Yorker, born and
raised, and was desperate
for this Bored and
Brilliant challenge.
It's perfect.
I needed it.
I've definitely developed
some compulsions
for Facebook, Instagram,
checking the news,
checking email, replying
to email right away,
texting, hunting
for funny emojis.
I just-- I just need
a break from my phone
because I'm not sure that
these activities really add
all that much value to my life.
And they certainly take
up a lot of my time.
[END PLAYBACK]
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: OK, so
[? Carin ?] and I, for one week
in 2015-- every
morning we woke up,
and we put out a
little podcast that
explained the neuroscience of
what is going on in your brain
when you actually get bored.
It describes some of
the technology's design,
in terms of getting our
attention and how we use it.
And it asked them to do
a very small behavior
change, something
to try that day just
to see what would happen,
and then report back to us.
And so, what we learned--
and I found that this
was fascinating-- we
are at an extraordinary
moment when
it comes to understanding
what happens in the brain when
the mind wanders.
It's like-- it's really
hot news in neuroscience.
So it turns out that
when you get bored,
you ignite a network in your
brain called the default mode.
And in the default mode, we
have our most original thoughts.
We do our most
creative thinking.
We take two seemingly
disparate ideas,
we smash them together,
and create a new idea.
And we do something that I
had never heard of before,
called autobiographical
planning.
This is where you look
back at your earlier life
that you've had, and you take
note of the highs and the lows,
and you build a
personal narrative,
and then decide, you know, where
am I going to go from here?
What are my goals?
And you set the steps that
you need to reach those.
And so, kind of important stuff
that is going on in your brain.
And it also turns out
that a decade ago, we
shifted our attention at
work about every 3 minutes.
And now, we're
shifting our attention
at work every 45 seconds.
I found this amazing researcher.
Her name is Dr. Gloria Mark.
She's a professor of
informatics at UC Irvine.
And she told me that the average
person is switching tasks
at work 566 times a day.
So what I asked
Gloria was, I said,
is it because the
technology has been
designed to take our attention
and get us switching like that?
Or is this just a
human thing that,
if it wasn't the
technology, we'd
be distracted by something else?
And here was her answer.
GLORIA MARK: So I think
it's a combination.
One thing that we found
is that there's actually
physiological reasons that
can explain why people shift
their attention so rapidly.
So we find that when
people are stressed,
they tend to shift their
attention more rapidly.
We also found, strangely
enough, the shorter amount
of sleep, that a person
gets, the more likely
they are to check Facebook.
So we're in this
vicious habitual cycle.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: I mean, I
thought that was hilarious
and made complete
and utter sense,
because when I am
tired at night,
that is when I find myself
going like this on my phone,
and not even looking at
whatever it is that I thought
I was looking for.
And of course, I mean, I
think that has been a wake up
call for a lot of
Americans, this idea
that if the product is free,
then you are the product.
And we're seeing that
conversation be more and more
prevalent and more mainstream.
So really, the most
gratifying, I found,
was that a lot of classrooms
across the country
did the Bored and Brilliant
project, mostly high schools
and freshmen college kids.
And here's how I
put it in the book.
"Talking, listening,
eye contact, downtime,
responsiveness,
and yes, boredom,
are all activities that
now need to actively
be put into practice.
It's not that digital
natives don't feel or know
these things.
It's just that they
don't get prioritized.
And so, we must name,
schedule, and celebrate them,
whether it's the effect
that reading on screen
has on our attention
spans, or video game play
has on sociability, or
taking photos has on memory,
we're living in an age
of self-experimentation.
Technology is evolving faster
than researchers can study it.
Science can't keep
up, which is why
we need a new interdisciplinary
approach, like the one we could
offer with Bored and Brilliant.
Research now needs to
move out of the lab,
because life is the new lab."
So just in case you think,
like, it's not a detox--
I absolutely refuse
to use that word,
because I don't
think it's a binary.
It's not on or off, right?
I think what we're
finding is that users need
to understand how it
fits into their lives
and turn their phones from what
have become task masters back
into tools that actually
improve their lives.
And right now, they're not
feeling like they're-- a lot
of them are feeling like
they're not there yet.
And I just want to play you
a clip so one of the days
that we had was called Delete
That App, where we asked people
to take the app that was
driving them bonkers bananas
off their phone,
just for the day.
You know, you don't have
to quit it, whatever.
Just delete that off
your phone so it's not
following you around.
And I want to play you a clip
from a listener named Liam,
who did the original project.
LIAM: This is Liam
in Los Angeles.
And I deleted Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram, Tumblr, Snapchat
and Vine from my phone
in one fell swoop.
And it was kind of an
embarrassingly emotional
experience at first.
It felt weirdly lonely to
look at that lock screen
with no new notifications on it.
But I really like
deciding for myself
when to think about or
access my social networks,
not giving my phone the
power to decide that for me.
So, thank you.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: I love Liam.
He's such an extremist, right?
He's like, I'm taking
them all off, all of them!
OK, so people took all
kinds of things off.
They took social media off.
They took games.
Some people took news off,
if you've got a headline
refreshing habit.
But I will say, the
other thing that we
did during the original
project was that we partnered
with two different apps.
And I did get some
push-back on that.
People were like,
wait, you're telling
us to download certain apps
in order to take apps off?
I was like, look, we've got
to meet people where they are.
So Moment was for the iPhone.
Break Free was for Android.
And what they did was measure
how many minutes a day
they were on their phone,
and how many pickups a day
they were on their phone.
So we were able
to have thousands
of people contributing
their data back to us.
And we were able
to measure which
days activities
were more effective
and which ones sort of were not.
So the first time around in
2015, I was totally winging it.
I just made all
the experiments up.
I was like, I don't
know, let's try this.
But what we were able to
do was go back and look
at all the data and the
stories, and codify it
into what is now
the book, of course.
So in the end, we had
20,000 people that one week,
all 50 states.
We measured that
90 percent of them
cut down on their phone
time, which, you know,
I kind of feel like,
OK, that's great.
But really, the
more important thing
was that 70 percent felt as
though they had more time
to just think, which, I mean--
I just did a TED talk, and
they were like, I don't know,
is that going to be enough
that, like, your message is
that people need to think?
I was like, shocking, right?
Liam got back in
touch two weeks ago,
because I did a shout
out to my listeners.
And I was like, do you
remember the project
that we did in 2015?
I've got this book coming out.
They totally remembered.
Liam got back to me,
and he said, actually,
I never put the apps back
on my phone after that week.
I just decided that I liked
things better without them.
So here's what he told me.
LIAM: I'm currently on an
incredible trip to Europe,
and I've stayed off
Facebook this whole time.
Every time I ponder posting
a photo from my adventures,
I think about how I'd keep
checking to see who liked it.
And I think about how seeing
other people's adventures
on Facebook nine
times out of ten
ends up making me feel
depressed by comparing my life
to my perception of theirs.
There's something about sharing
my life very sparingly now
that makes my experience
a little richer and more
introspective.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: So I was
like, OK, Liam's the extremist.
Of course, he's going
to be all dramatic.
He's an actor in LA, by the
way, so of course, there's
drama there.
But it turns out,
a lot of people
made changes that
stuck with them.
NAOMI: Hey, Note-to-Self.
My name is Naomi, and I did
the Bored and Brilliant Project
back in 2015.
One thing I did was delete
the Facebook app off my phone.
And two years later,
I still don't have it.
SPEAKER 1: I recently started
to use [INAUDIBLE] as my Boredom
points.
It feels a little uncomfortable.
But I think letting
my thoughts wander
is important to take
charge of my life.
SPEAKER 2: At night, I
leave the phone downstairs
and turned off.
And when I go on walks with my
wife, I don't even bring it.
SPEAKER 3: I deleted
the Instagram app
because I was noticing
every time I logged on,
I would get kind
of a stomach ache,
like that anxiety stomach ache.
And I thought, I
don't need this.
It's a time waster.
And it doesn't bring me joy.
So I'm deleting it.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: But I just
want to tell you about one
of my favorite stories.
This is from Vanessa
in Wisconsin.
So the Bored and Brilliant
Project happened, she
was going through a breakup.
She had to decide what she
was going to do about the farm
that she owned with her partner.
She did the project,
and then at the end,
she decided that
she bought her--
they broke up.
She bought the farm
full, outright.
And then decided that she
needed to do something
with the farm for the community.
So she renamed it
Make Time Farm.
And now, once a
month, she has a day
where she invites people to
come and just kind of hang out.
There's a basket if they want
to put their phone in there.
People bring their sewing
machine, their watercolor.
They do all kinds of things.
They nap.
I would like to go to
Vanessa's farm and take a nap.
That would be nice.
They also, like,
think about, like,
goal-setting, and
things like that.
So Vanessa sort of decided
that this was something
that she wanted to
have in her life,
and for the community,
which was great.
And so now, with the book, I
am reaching a whole different
category of people who--
it's interesting what
kind of reaction.
Some people are podcast
people who know the show,
and know sort of
the things that we
talk about on the show, which
are a lot of ethics related.
And other people. have
never heard of it at all,
but this is something that's
sort of been on their mind
and they want to explore.
So I'm going around the country.
And I'm having lots of fun.
And I'm making people take
selfies, because as I said,
this is not an all or
nothing sort of thing.
There are moms
going out drinking
before they come to hang out
with me, which has been great.
And I thought this
review was really funny,
that "This could do
for unplugging what
Marie Kondo's 'The Life
Changing Magic of Tidying Up'
did for decluttering."
I mean, I love that.
That would be great, if I
was as big as Marie Kondo.
But to me, what's more
interesting is really,
since I finished
writing this book,
a lot has changed
in this country.
It is really hard not
to continually refresh
the headlines, or Twitter.
Just ask the president.
But I think perhaps
it's time for us
to collectively rethink
some of our tech habits,
because the other
thing that happens
when you ignite the default
mode is you do empathy.
You imagine what other people
around you are thinking,
and how they're feeling.
And if there is one thing this
country could use right now,
is a little empathy, and
some creative problem solving
to sort of find solutions to
some huge economic, racial,
and environmental issues.
And so, I think particularly
for young people
to understand that quickness
isn't necessarily a virtue,
or as the Exchequer of
the Bank of England said,
he's worried that quick thinking
could make for slow growth.
So this is not just a, you
know, self-help-y sort of thing,
but I think, really,
an economic thing,
that we need people
to take a minute
and let a mediocre idea that
they might want to share just
sit on it for a little while.
Let it turn into
something bigger.
Let it turn into a big solution,
which a lot of young people
are not used to doing.
So I'm just telling
people to get bored.
That's all I want them to
do, on this big book tour
that I'm on right now.
And you heard about the podcast.
You've heard about my
listeners experience,
some of the new people
that I'm meeting.
And I would love to
talk to you guys,
because you're the
first tech company
that I've gone to to
make this presentation.
So I would love to hear,
like, what your thoughts are
on this, your comments, any
questions, personal experience.
That would be great.
And thank you for having me.
RODNEY: Great.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Mic over here is
open for questions,
for anyone who would like.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: I also love--
I mean, I'm sure
you're all like, oh,
my god, another anti-tech
person-- but like,
really, I really want to
hear what you guys think.
One of the people in the
book is Tristan Harris.
Have you heard of--
he was a Google
ethicist for a little while.
And now, he's created
his own sort of--
starting to think about ways
that the tech could build
in ways of making
people communicate
more sort of in tune
with setting expectations
of other people.
So I'd love to know
what you guys think.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I would be curious to know
how much this affects someone's
work life balance, if they're
checking their work email
and other work
applications on the phone.
And I wondered if you
looked into that--
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Yeah.
So there's one chapter in
particular focused on workplace
reasons, because what I hear
from a lot of people who
come to these events
is, they're like, well,
I work in social media.
How am I supposed
to take time off?
So from a personal perspective,
I think having-- in the book,
I really try to
lay out how being
productive-- we
have to re-imagine
what being productive is.
So for me, in my own personal--
when I'm riding the subway home,
I used to think, like, great,
this is my time to just
jam through email, right?
Like, I'm going to hit it.
But now I realize,
actually, no, this
is 30 minutes of me where I can
actually do some solid thinking
about something that's been
bothering me all day long,
or a work issue that I haven't
had time to sort of really
drive into.
So I've had to rethink what
productivity actually means.
And what I'm hoping--
so there's a whole chapter
about specifically how
we define productivity
and problem solving.
And then, there's also--
so the challenge that day
is to take a fake-cation,
which is to reset the
expectations of the people who
are hoping to hear
from you, right,
because I think that's the
other thing that we've found,
is that when we're waiting in
line for coffee, you're like,
oh, this is an opportunity--
these two minutes--
are an opportunity
to show my spouse
how I'm thinking of them,
or that I'm on top of,
like, you know, what's for
dinner, or my coworkers,
that I know that we
needed to follow up on x--
so resetting
expectations by setting
outgoing messages, which I
think a lot of people don't do.
And so I tell people,
like, you know,
even if it's for a half an hour,
if your outgoing message says,
I'm working on
something, and that's
why you're not
hearing from me, it's
resetting their expectations.
And other people are like, my
boss will never accept that.
And I'm like, OK, so you have
a stomach virus for one hour,
you know what I mean?
Like, do what you've got to do,
because it's really important.
But then, the other
thing that I've done
is I joined a silent workspace,
where there's no talking.
There's no eating, so no
crinkle, crinkle with, like--
I love my snacks,
but none of that.
And for me, like, I've realized
the most important work
I do every week is
my writing, right?
And I know that I need
that three to four hours.
I've tried to write
the show in less,
or I've tried to do it while I'm
jumping in and out of meetings.
It doesn't work.
I need the three to four hours.
And so, I joined this workspace.
I don't get there more than,
like, once or twice a week.
But I think it's
worth it for me.
So my fantasy is
that every company
has a silent workspace
where, you know,
it's seen as productive
that you're going in there,
and not talk--
yeah, right?
We're clapping in the front.
Wouldn't that be amazing,
like, if you were like,
no, I've got serious work to do?
Because I don't know about you
guys, but like, in my office--
first of all, radio people,
oh my god, they never
stop talking.
And there's a lot of
this, like, oh my god, I'm
so sorry I'm totally
interrupting you--
and then they start talking.
And you're like, no, like,
yes, you were interrupting me.
So that's my big fantasy.
And like, Susan Cain, she's--
I definitely quote her in the
book, The Quiet Revolution.
But I think we
need to codify it.
And it's not just
for introverts.
Extroverts need to, like, be
quiet and do the hard work,
too.
So does that--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think it makes a lot of sense.
One of the things I
found was I recently
took my corporate
account off of my phone.
So I just have my personal
account on the phone--
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Interesting.
And how's that going?
AUDIENCE: I was--
I had difficulty
with it at first,
because it was something
I was just constantly--
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Sure.
AUDIENCE: --accustomed to
having there on the phone.
But I found that, A, my battery
lasts longer on the phone,
because it's not constantly
updating high volumes of email,
B, it's something where I
don't just compulsively start
checking the work email--
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --and getting engaged
into the work-related tasks,
and--
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: I'm so guilty.
Like, I mean, all I do is
think about my podcast.
It's all I do.
And if it were up to me,
I'd be emailing and pinging
my producers all day long.
And like, you know,
I've got to, like,
walk the talk here, right?
So I try to save up and, like,
make my communication with them
meaningful and
constructive, as opposed to,
like, what you guys think
about yada, yada, yada?
Gloria Mark, that wonderful
informatics professor--
you guys are, like, the only
audience I think I've ever had
that actually knows what
an informatics person is,
by the way--
she tried out-- this
kind of cracked me up--
she tried out a
mini Japanese zen
garden where she could put--
in an office where everybody
had a mini Japanese zen garden.
And depending on the
formation of the rocks,
it indicated to your coworkers
whether you were in deep work
or whether you were willing
to be in conversation.
So my team got me
a mini zen garden.
It doesn't work.
But it looks pretty, though.
But Tristan, the person
that I mentioned,
he was talking
about this idea of,
what if we could have
Google Docs where you had,
like, a pause button
that was like, hey,
I'm in the middle
of working on this.
Give me-- it'll
ping you when I'm
ready for you to come
and look what I do,
because as a podcast person,
we run on Google Docs.
I mean, everything
is in Google Docs.
And it drives me
bananas when I'm
in the middle of
writing something,
and I see my producer's
face show up.
I'm like, get out.
I am doing something
here, you know?
But how do you, like-- hey,
can you come back later,
basically, is what
I have to say.
So it'd be so nice to, like,
snooze it or something, or--
and I think it's resetting
expectations, you know?
AUDIENCE: Well then, one
final question about this is,
are there any
companies that you're
aware of that are doing
the analytics feedback
to the employees so that they
are given a nudge to separate
their work life environment?
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Yeah,
so the big example
that I use is Boston Consulting
Group, where they did--
it was part of a
study that was done
by Leslie Purlow at
Harvard, where they tried
different ways of
setting up groups, where
one person in a group was
told to take time off,
like, specifically.
And they were told
to, like, cook,
hang out with your family.
And they knew that another group
member was covering for them.
And BCG had been experiencing
really rapid turnover
and burn out.
And so, they wanted to see if
this would make a difference.
And their retention
levels went, like, way up.
So that's the example I use.
I think there are.
I don't know a ton of
people trying it out.
But I think if we start to think
of it as a way to, you know,
cut back on costs
because we don't have
to hire as many people,
deal with the burnout
that so many places are seeing,
because we're working all
the time, but also think
of it as, like, you know,
working smarter, not
necessarily harder.
So, thanks for your question.
Hello.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
also guilty of the--
I call it micro-efficiency,
where I try to extract every,
like, thing I can out of
every minute of the day--
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: I love that.
Can I use that,
micro-efficiency?
AUDIENCE: Sure, go ahead.
And last year, as a
way to kind of help
myself not do that anymore is,
I joined the meditation group
at Google.
And they encourage
that by donating money.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI:
Megan's in the book.
AUDIENCE: Oh, really?
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Yeah, totally.
He's been on the show.
He's awesome.
AUDIENCE: So I guess my
question was, do you do--
in the course of
writing the book,
did you find that meditation
also helped with this,
with increasing
creativity and kind of--
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --putting life
on pause for a little bit?
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: It's
a different thing.
Meditation ignites a
different part of the brain.
It is completely different
than the mind wandering part.
So the mind wandering thing
is when you are doing nothing.
So it could be, like,
repetitive folding of laundry,
or it could be walking
to work, or something
that doesn't require active
focus on what you're doing.
The idea with
meditation is that there
is active focus on thinking
about nothing, right,
or the clearing of the mind.
That is what you are focused on.
And so that is its own thing.
But this is truly letting--
the mind wandering part
goes into daydreaming.
And it can also go
to some bad places.
I mean, let's make no mistake.
Just because you
let your mind wander
doesn't mean like, holy shit,
you have the next great startup
idea, right?
There's dysphoric
thinking, which
is a rumination, which is
going to be me tomorrow,
going over this talk, and how
some of the PowerPoint slides
fired themselves, and how much
that annoyed me, and thinking,
you know, if only I
could go back to Google
and give that talk
over-- you know,
I'm going to be
thinking about that, OK.
So that's not good.
Then there's also
the distraction kind,
which is people who just
ping all over the place when
your mind is wandering.
I'm certainly guilty
of that, as well.
But then there's
the wonderful kind,
which is positive
constructive mind wandering.
This was Jerome
Singer, who did some
of the most deep pioneering
work on mind wandering.
And that is when we start to
do that wonderful constructive
type of mind wandering.
But Tade Mengteng, the
guy who I think you're
referring to, who started the
Google Inside Yourself course--
is that something that,
like, everybody knows about
at Google, or is that, like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Yeah?
Say that again.
AUDIENCE: There's
signs sometimes.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Oh, OK.
OK.
And have any of you done it?
Anyone?
OK, all right.
Yeah, so, the sense I got is,
like, it's relatively popular.
So he talks about the
different kinds of meditation
that there are.
And I think if you're getting
positive benefits from those,
it's great.
I mean, no reason not
to continue to do it.
And this would
just-- mind wandering
would be a separate but also
equally wonderful thing.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Cool, thanks.
AUDIENCE: So this idea
of kind of default mode
and a neurological basis for
this is really interesting.
So I'm curious, I guess, what
is the sort of definition
of boredom?
So, like, for example,
the experience
of walking down a nice
trail is very different
from the experience
of, you know,
walking down New York City--
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --or even running
versus walking, I feel,
are kind of different.
So I'm curious if there's sort
of activities or environments
that are more boring than
others, or if it matters?
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: So I
got a lot of push-back
when I first used the
word boredom on the show.
People were like, could you call
it something a little nicer,
please, like daydreaming?
And I was like, no, actually,
boredom is the perfect word,
because I think that is
really what we're seeing,
is that why do we
distract ourselves?
Because we feel uncomfortable.
And if you look at the
history of boredom,
I mean, there's a really
nerdy chapter on that, too,
which is that the word
didn't appear until 1853.
Charles Dicken's
"Bleak House," boredom.
And it makes sense, right?
Industrial Revolution,
people have more free time.
They have time to be bored.
But if you look
back even further,
Kierkegaard preferred
the word idle.
The French called it ennui.
I'm thinking of other
philosophers who've
describe it as this sort
of existential angst
that we have-- what is
my purpose here on earth,
Heidegger in particular.
So for me, using
the word bored--
I think there are
those of us who
find mind wandering
wonderful, or maybe we
used to think it was boring,
but now we think it's great.
I think parents, in
particular, who never have
time to get bored, like it.
But I really specifically wanted
to use that word because I
think some people-- particularly
I see this with young people--
think that they
can skip straight
to the good original
thinking stuff, that like,
an apple's going to
drop on their head,
and they're going to
have a great idea.
And I feel like,
no, actually, you're
going to-- it's going to hurt.
It's going to be painful.
It's going to suck until
the good stuff comes.
I gave the book
earlier this summer
to a chemistry major, a
student at American University,
and had him record
his experience.
And you hear him just
like, oh my god, I
don't want to do this.
I really don't want to do
this-- just really struggling.
I don't recognize this feeling.
Normally, I would
just look at my phone
whenever I have these feelings.
And then you get
to like, Day Five.
And he goes for this
walk in Rock Creek Park.
And he's like, I'm
just going to do it.
I'm just going to, you know,
succumb to the mind wandering.
And he comes up with
this amazing idea
related to solar
panels and the hometown
that he grew up in,
in Puerto Rico, which
has a disproportionate
amount of churches
that have a lot of roof,
square footage, that could be--
I mean, he just goes off
on this crazy tangent.
And like, we kind
of heard, like,
an epiphany happening on there.
So I think
particularly teenagers
said to me when
they did it, like,
oh, I don't like this feeling.
I don't recognize it.
I was like, yeah,
that's boredom.
So just like, stick with it.
Lean into it.
But it's however you
kind of define it.
It's as personalized as your
home screen, I would say.
Anybody else?
RODNEY: All right,
well, thank you
so much for joining us
and sharing with us.
MANOUSH ZOMORODI: Yeah,
it was a pleasure.
Anybody thinks that--
I mean, I really
want to know, like, do you
think this is total bullshit?
Like, I really, really--
[LAUGHTER]
--like, I'm really open to it,
because I think-- you know,
I was at Powell's last
night in Portland.
And I was like, oh, I'm
going to Google tomorrow.
And some people in the
audience were like, ooh.
I was like, really?
Should I be nervous?
But then, I had a lot of--
like, a guy from Apple
came up afterwards,
and was telling me about
all these great hacks
that he has to,
like, keep people
from bugging him on his phone.
I was like, dude,
you should tell us.
I didn't know that you could
do, like, some of the things
that you're telling me.
Like, we should all know
about these little hacks,
because I think it would
make people feel a lot better
about their tech use.
I mean, I love my phone.
I love my phone.
But I see that it really plays
into some of my weaknesses.
I'm a human and I am deeply
flawed, and my phone knows it.
And it just knows how
to bring it out in me.
So it's been a really
interesting conversation
that I'm having with people.
And I'm really grateful for
any feedback you can give me.
I really am.
So, thanks again for having me.
I'm going to hang out if you
have something you, like, don't
want-- if you want to shame me
in front of your colleagues,
or something like that.
That's cool, too.
[APPLAUSE]